i am here with creative director of
world's edge adam eyes green and adam
i'm so excited to talk h4 of course
because you've brought something a
little different and very special today
uh yeah i have so you know so far we've
been showing everyone kind of what age
looks like from in the game you know
when you're playing it you've got to see
a lot of footage of that and we've also
shown a little bit of our campaigns
right through uh when we unveiled the
100 years war and show joan of arc but
we have yet another way in age of
empires 4 that we're kind of bringing
history life that we haven't talked
about yet see you do this to me
you put me in suspense i want to know
more so let's go with it let's hear more
okay wait you get one moment of suspense
okay that's enough so um what we brought
today is um we have these wonderful
little videos that we've created that
are interspersed amongst the campaign
and they're about three to five minutes
each
and um
we have over an hour of them total and
they're called hands-on histories and
what they are is a great way to like
deep dive on certain fun subjects from
the cultures we're representing and just
from medieval history excellent well i
hear you've actually brought one of
those segments that you're gonna share
here for the very first time yes um i
have uh we are going to show you the
segments on one of the most popular
units from age of empires franchise and
a fan favorite the trebuchet excellent
well this i gotta see
let's
take a look
a counterweight trebuchet
was the king of all siege engines
a catapult capable of smashing down
castle walls from great distances
at warwick castle in england
they've built a replica one of the
largest in the world
[Music]
originating in 7th century china by the
13th century trebuchets had evolved into
devastatingly powerful weapons
such a simple design but so effective
it has several key features
a pivoted arm with a weight at one end
and a sling
to hold the projectile at the other
to prime the six ton weight is raised
using tread wheels
so this is one of the wheels one of two
that's attached to an axle
which would lift the counterweight
weighing six tons
it's based on muscle power alone
what's essential about launching a
projectile as far as possible is making
sure that this end of the arm is moving
as fast as possible so once that weight
drops it really sends this point of the
arm moving at its highest velocity
this was done by positioning the pivot
close to the counterweight
and by launching the projectile from a
sling
when released
the sling whips around
vastly increasing the launch speed
trebuchets were carefully aimed
like modern guns
in order to weaken the castle walls or
even breach them you had to make sure
that the projectiles hit the same spot
every single time
for each projectile to follow the same
trajectory
they all had to be the same weight and
shape
to achieve this
mason's used a gauge
now i'm going to load this projectile
into the sling oh this one must weigh
about 25 kilograms but some projectiles
can get up to 150 kilograms that's the
weight of two men
trebuchets were also used to throw
burning tar
bee hives
even dead bodies
anything to cause maximum distress to
the enemy
do you hear that whoosh
it was the counterweight trebuchet's
lethal combination of power and accuracy
that made it the ultimate medieval siege
weapon
you know i'm going to say trebuche
don't care because that is awesome and
remarkably unique something you don't
see in games very often
yeah so you know one of the the things
when we were looking at what we're going
to do with age of empires 4
there's a phrase i'm really fond of
which is history is only as interesting
as the people who taught it to you and
you could say that about any subject
really right but i think the great thing
is is when you have someone that's so
enthusiastic and passionate about
history it really comes across and we
wanted to be that kind of teacher for
history
and um
there's a phrase called humanized
history that i use to kind of describe
what we tried to do which is we try to
like connect past and present and you
can see that kind of in our briefings as
well where we've got like real stuff
with like cg kind of overlaid to show
you the history and so for these
we really wanted to do that same thing
so we we my ourselves and relic
partnered with this amazing group in the
uk called lion tv and they've done
production on an amazing amount of shows
and documentaries for the bbc and one
every award you can imagine for media
and they travel to all of these
locations and all these different
countries to meet with these subject
matter experts and get all of this great
footage on how things really worked and
how things were made and it's been
delightful to kind of go through that
process and you know get all these and
finally start showing them to everyone i
love it now you you also of course
you've got a bunch as you mentioned of
these hands-on history segments anything
else that you can tell us fans about
what we can expect looking forward to
any favorites you got coming up oh well
favorites oh man well um i think my
personal favorite is one called medieval
surgery and i'm gonna let your
imagination go with what we might show
and what we might talk about in that one
yeah um but the thing i love about them
is that they they they go all over the
place so you know we've got ones on
warfare and castle building and like how
they kept flaming arrows from not going
out when she shot them and um so uh but
we've also got all of these ones on you
know like illuminated history and um
hawk falconing and you know like horse
taming armor creation um
and even there's even one on mongolian
instrumentation which is really cool
because those instruments we actually
use them in the soundtrack
for the mongols when you're playing as
them in the campaign and in the game
i mean i i just love the behemoth amount
of history that you guys agent empire is
always known for bringing history alive
in a completely different way and i also
love to mention this to people that you
and the team do so much research and
it's so great to see this approach being
used in a hands-on history kind of
segment but i mean what was that
approach like to sort of you know sell
going forward especially since it's are
you such a unique in-game experience
well the cool thing was it was there
from day one it was one of the things i
was really wanted to do is try to tell
these stories in a different way and but
i'll tell you like full disclosure has
been insanely nerve-wracking because
we're trying something completely
different that no one's ever done before
in a game right we're like we're history
but we're a game but we're teaching you
things but you're having fun and um
finding that middle ground has been
really challenging and you know every
time we've tried to show we've shown the
campaigns or we've shown these hands-on
histories i've been like oh god
it's going to work like people gonna
like this and the great thing is so far
everyone that's really experienced the
entire thing put together had just been
like wow this is great and it's so
different and kind of cool and
refreshing so uh
so far so good right but yeah it's been
it's been a journey you know to get all
this done and put the whole game
together well i love that you mentioned
journey because we are coming towards
the end of this development journey for
age four
talk to me about where people can find
and learn more about age of empires four
i know they're all chomping at the bit
oh well you know october 28th uh we are
launching the game uh you can go to age
of empires dot com to learn more about
the title and if you're really really
excited right now you can go on to the
microsoft store or steam pre-order the
game right now and of course we will be
there day one xbox game pass for pc as
well so anyone that's on that can just
grab the game and start playing
awesome but yes i believe you are a part
of something very special yes so
gamescom opening night live yes
11 a.m pacific time um there might be
something age vampires related in there
so if you're a fan you probably should
tune in oh a bit of a tease from mr ice
green
and i like it very much adam thank you
so much for joining us here always a
pleasure kate always a pleasure age of
empires 4 looks fantastic so i cannot
wait october 28th neither should you now
we have tons coming up here today
including a new update for state of
decay 2 and an extended look at forza
horizon 5 with our friends at playground
games but now let's catch up with parry
who's gone from flying the skies and
microsoft flights him to a different
kind of cloud